вчитись ніколи не пізно і це вже не
просто вислів а мотивація до дії
Верховна Рада ухвалила законопроєкт про
освіту дорослих і якщо за нього
проголосують у другому читанні і підпише
президенту українці зможуть вчитися
безперервно протягом усього життя
здобувати нові спеціальності і
перекваліфіковуватися будуть створені
центри освіти для дорослих та цифрового
освітнього портфоліо і докладніше про це
ми зараз будемо наживо говорити з нашим
гостем Сергій шкарлет Міністр освіти і
науки України доєднався до нашої ефіру Я
вас вітаю пане міністр Слава Україні
Отже одразу
Чемпіонату світу дорослих Давайте
поговоримо це законодавча врегулювання
було однією з умов Євросоюзу ото
Поясніть чому питання є настільки
важливим саме для Європи
Дуже дякую вам за запитання Дуже дякую
вам за увагу за увагу до сфери освіти
оскільки сфера освіти це про майбутнє
про життя про розвиток держави України
компетентностей навичок
пропозитив і про те що Україна має
відбутися відбулася і має відбутися
хочу дійсно сказати що закон про освіту
дорослих Це був Урядовий законопроект
який готували фахівці Міністерства
освіти і науки разом з командою нашої
еристі ми його подавали на розгляд
комітету Дуже дякую депутатам які
підтримали цей законопроект і в цьому
контексті дійсно він йшов в пакеті як
євроінтеграційний оскільки Ну в принципі
сьогодні в світі багато таких
організацій Скажімо так конкретно Юнеско
беруть участь у різного роду проектах і
дослідженнях цієї
проблематики оскільки на сьогодні голову
кута кожної людини ставиться розвиток
власних національних систем освіти
впродов
для країни Європейського Союзу
важливість цього питання полягає в тому
що в першу чергу Має бути чітко
визначені питання демографії
наповненості ринку праці високоякісними
фахівцями і спроможність до економічної
конкуренції країн Європейського Союзу
взагалі європейського ринку з усіма
іншими світовими економічними гравцями
три основні напрямки сфери освіти
дорослих які є в Європейському Союзі які
були
орієнтирами для нас під підготовці цього
закону це формування базових освітніх
навичок у дорослих включно з навичками в
навичками самовдосконалення і можливості
продовжитись навчання це формування
досконалення професійних навичок і
формування громадянських навичок у
найбільш широкому сенсі розуміння цього
саме це і було реалізовано в базовому
контексті цього
законопроекту який прийнятий в першому
читанні урядового законопроекту про
освіту дорослих Дуже дякую
а для кого в першу чергу він має бути
корисним
на кого спрямований закон перш за все в
голову
також Знову ті взагалі нереативи які
використовував один з кращих міністрів
освіти України Василь Григорович Кремень
його ідеологію і теорію людиноцентризму
і саме в центрі законопроекту ми поклали
людину і норми закону розглядають саме
людину в трьох таких іпостазаціях людина
громадянин
людина-працівник і людина особистість і
на наш погляд саме в цьому контексті ми
максимально зробили для того щоб
освітньою активністю охопити все
населення незалежно від віку Дуже дякую
вам
чому спитала тому що ми ж живемо в
умовах війни І от нині переселенці
військовослужбовці які отримали
поранення і в них немає кінцівок А як
для них чи є якісь особливі умови і чи
скористаються вони в першу чергу цим
законом
скільки це скільки саме в законі Про
освіту дорослих ми внормовували питання
І коли людей які військовослужбовці які
мають бути звільнені в зла в Збройних
сил саме в цьому контексті ми чітко
відпрацювали з міністерства ветеранів з
профільним комітету Верховної Ради саме
працевлаштування спроможність добувати
освіту для людей які звільнили збиратись
була зла в Збройних сил саме для людей з
особливими освітніми потребами і на
сьогодні ми чітко працюють і з
конфедерацією роботодавців підписавши
Вчора меморанду ми сьогодні реалізуємо з
міжнародною організацією праці великий
проект який стосується саме
працевлаштування людей з особливими
освітніми потребами це така досить
шепетільна для держави сфера і ми в
цьому контексті як Міністерство освіти
разом з конфігурацією роботодавців саме
в цьому контексті її
Ми сьогодні розглядаємо в цьому
контексті і осіб з інвалідністю
внаслідок війни
інші особливості освітні потреби освіти
особи які визнані учасником бойових дій
і зокрема з
тих з них які сьогодні вже проходять
військову службу особу які визнані
учасниками бойових дій і мають вступ має
право на вступ до закладів вищої освіти
де безоплатного здобуття вищої освіти Ми
на сьогодні за допомогою депутатів
прийняли законопроект який закон який
дозволяє внести зміни до закону Про
освіту який дозволяв отримувати
професійно-технічну освіту
не було
Дякую
цифрове портфоліо Розкажіть нам
докладніша що це що воно собою
представлятиме для чого
ви знаєте цифровий портфоліо сьогодні
взагалі централізація змінили світ і
оскільки з нашими партнерами з
міністерством цифрових трансформації Ми
дуже активно запроваджуємо цілу низку
цифрових ініціатив в цьому в цьому
взагалі в контексті держава Україна є
сьогодні лідером серед всього світу і ми
сьогодні співпрацюючи з міністерством
цифрової трансформації ну перш за все
ставимо в голову кута так званий
цифрової освітній паспорт для дитини
оскільки оскільки і ковід і війна на
сьогодні для деяких категорій
деяких територій деяких категорій
унеможливлює навчання в традиційному
очному форматі Ми дуже багато Саме
цифрові навички саме цифрові інструменти
в цифровому портфоліо Міністерства
освіти і науки відіграють ключову роль
сьогодні для збереження доступності до
освіти всіх категорій наших громадян
всіх категорій дітей незалежно від цих
дошкільного шкільна навіть позашкільна
це і студенти і крок техосвіта і в цьому
контексті в нас на сьогодні Ну наприклад
один з елементів цифрового портфоліо є
Так звана наша всеукраїнська школа
онлайн як в якій на сьогодні більше ніж
пів мільйона користувачів з 134 країн
світу а війна трошки розкидала наших
учнів і але на сьогодні ми маємо цифрові
інструмент який дозволяє певним чином
дітям мати доступ до освітнього процесу
незалежно від місця перебування в нас є
на сьогодні навіть провив вступ який
запроваджений пробував в 2022 році і у
нас у місцях 180 000 осіб а в тому числі
20 000 наших випускників з-за кордону
змогли за використанням цифрових
технологій вступити до закладів вищої
освіти України
в нас на сьогодні відкриті можливості
доступу до світових джерел інформації і
набуття навичок і певних слів Це так
звана курс серія гедонс на збільшенні 40
тисяч е-е студентів зареєстровано за
допомогою цього цифрового контенту на
здобуття додаткових освітніх навичок
окрім того ми сьогодні маємо в на
платформі всеукраїнської школи онлайн
інструменти діагностичної діагностичного
тестування з математики української мови
для того щоб оцінити наявні освітні
розриви які приміськові та те що війна і
Саме цей інструмент доступний для учнів
п'ятий сьомий і дев'ятий класів і ми
постійно будемо розширювати
окрім того в цифровий контент входить не
тільки софт А ще і
програмне забезпечення парад
незалежності
Ми сьогодні в співпраці з компанією
Google вже отримали більше ніж 50 тисяч
корундуків захілі фактором та
організацією юнісеф Нам вдалося
назбирати більше ніж 100 тисяч ноутбуків
для вчителів які сьогодні є інструментом
який дає можливість вчителю мати доступ
абсолютно то до всіх достукатись до всіх
своїх дітей і демонструвати якість
освітнього процесу Ми продовжуємо
встигнемо з вами поговорити про дітей а
саме щодо вищої освіти для молодшого
покоління чи зміниться цього року
порядок вступу до вишів
ви знаєте я би хотів би попросити вас
трошки
відкласти це питання до п'ятниці
оскільки в нас разом з профільним
комітетом буде широкий брифінг на 9
годин ранку там де ми більш детально Я з
головою комітету з депутатами з головою
підкомітету будемо чітко презентувати
модель вступу 2023 яка
як на нас найбільш об'єктивно буде
давати можливість вступу до закладів
вищої освіти в 2023 році просто з
розумінням до цього поставитись адже ми
спільно напрацьовували цей контент
базово його надало Міністерство освіти і
науки як проєкт до цього були різні
дискусії дискусії від депутатів від
експертів але ми в понеділок дійшли
вже цільової згоди стосовно
базової моделі і будемо презентувати її
спільно з комітетом оскільки це наша
спільна робота наша спільна співпраця
Дуже дякую вам тобто я так розумію що ми
вже з вами домовилися про включення
прямий ефір правильно і ще до того ж
поговоримо
після брифінгу я задоволенням від
спеціально туди більше детально розповім
стосовно вступу стосовно можливостей
стосовно перспективи все інше але прошу
до брифінгу Просто трошки відкласти це
запитання Дуже дякую добре тоді чекатиме
на нову зустріч і дякую за ваші
відповіді Це був Сергій шкарлет Міністр
освіти і науки України